hi sunny this
cover just says like fall into me also
do you feel that way were you happy when
you saw the cover
i'm so happy drew actually the cover
comes
from a house that i walk by every day
when i'm on the bluffs and so i took a
picture of it
and i dream about that house i'm hoping
one day someone will just gift it to me
out of nowhere and just
be in their will and i showed it to my
editor and she's like
this is the house this is the house that
the book is centered on
and lo and behold there's the cover well
i had no idea i'm so glad i asked
yes well listen you are the queen of hot
topics and so
we would love to hit some headlines with
you
okay let's do it first up we're talking
about the
key to relationships everyone has a
different idea
on this topic and people reports that
saturday night lives
pete davidson the resident cutie
who's reportedly dating actress phoebe
denevere
says that his key is total
and complete honesty he isn't into
playing games he says that he's always
up front
he says this is who i am these are my
issues
here's the whole deal unfiltered sunny
thoughts i've been married for almost
23 years mazel tov and
i think pete is really sexy
really cute that's why he gets all the
hot girls he's really
funny's always really good um complete
honesty
i think he's on the wrong track there um
i think when you first get into a
relationship
um you need to send your representative
right because the person isn't really
hooked yet
so it's not about showing the good the
bad and the ugly it's just
showing the good it's showing the best
it's showing
what you could be it's trying to be the
best version of yourself
then once you're in it once the person's
hooked
once the person's in love works come out
that's when the crazy crazy
so you have me until then sunny world
that takes age and then you lose me
well listen it turns out that crazy is
going to come out at some point so do
you want it up front or in the back
yeah i just say put a bow on it
you know present the best version of you
and then reveal slowly
right because i tend
a little bit of the crazy but i don't
front load it yeah
don't front load the crazy write that
down for me hey
sonny question you know we're obsessed
with um
bridgeton did you watch it i'm obsessed
i burnt
reggae i burned for him oh bird oh good
news oh reggae jean well we have news on
him
cosmopolitan reports he is very much
taken
yes the duke has a duchess her name is
emily brown
and she's a copywriter and a part-time
soccer player that's what we know so far
friends say that she's witty and great
to be around
and emily and rey jean are so together
drew sunny they actually
live together o-m-g so are we we're
happy for them right i mean i'm still
not getting over the fact that he's not
going to be on bridgeton next year but
at least i know that he's happy
she's nice
i'm so happy for them
[Laughter]
this is so great i want your take on
this honey though
uh this is for my chicken fans out there
and i'm looking at
drew and sunny yeah
ac big media reports a cafe in phoenix
recently held something called chicken
yoga
the silky chickens are allowed to just
roam free during the yoga session
adding an extra layer of calm to the
class
and i think if you do yoga with chickens
around you get extra strong
breasts and thighs honey what do you
think of this story
um i love it i tend chickens i have
about 12 chickens right now
i'm in the pro i'm getting more um i
also have silkies and silkies are really
calm and they're really beautiful
beautiful souls
um and you know tending my chickens is
kind of like my happy place
i actually just got these
made for my eggs
i am so jealous that is so cool
isn't it cool because i hear that you
all sold 10 chickens so i'm gonna have
to have some of these made for you
oh sonny i would be so honored i not
only 10 chickens
my daughter olive taught percy
to swim this weekend oh my gosh
wow sorry can i just ask the chicken
swims
the chicken percy is now an official
swimmer and she just said you know i
want to teach all the chickens to swim
gosh forbid they
ever get out and they fall into some
water they have to know
how to take care of themselves and i
thought she was you know i was like
okay if percy is fully swimming
and you would think that percy would be
like
yes no calm as a cucumber loved the
whole process
ended up staying in the pool and like
hanging out all this chicken talk i
don't know what the clock is going on
well i know that we love sunny
and thank you so much for joining us
today i can't think of a better mind to
pick
than yours and catch her on the view and
pick up
your copy of summer on the bluffs
[Music]
you